let's talk about the southern border
because Governor Abbott in Texas has
said time and time again we can't afford
this we don't have the space for this
why is it all on Texas so why don't we
start sending them to Sanctuary states
where these are states that want these
individuals that want to pay use
taxpayer dollars to pay for these
individuals and so he sent another bus
of 37 migrants to uh to the front of
Vice President Harris's house in
Washington D.C you can see right here
this is exclusive video obtained by Fox
digital
yeah uh Pete they're saying right now go
ahead
oh go ahead no no I remember when this
first started when Governor Abbott and
others uh were dropping off migrants or
illegals inside New York and in the vice
president's house and there were some
prominent examples like Martha's
Vineyard I remember at first thinking
this feels a bit like a stunt it isn't
it hasn't been the cumulative effect of
this happening time and time again has
taken jurisdictions which otherwise
could ignore this problem pretend like
it doesn't exist it doesn't affect them
deny it and arrives on their doorstep
and now they're complaining saying we
didn't ask for this well nobody else
asked for it either Nashville Tennessee
didn't ask for it Minneapolis Minnesota
didn't ask for it across the country
this has become an issue that affects
everybody so keep dropping it on their
doorstep because they're the ones
facilitating the open border so what
they're doing now they've revamped since
saddle 42 went away and they're focusing
on title V
uh they're now having people check in in
Guatemala and another stop country and
instead of bringing them through the
Border we're paying for flights to fly
them directly to various cities so
people say wow the Border traffic has
dropped well a lot of it's because we're
putting them in uh 747s and fly them
directly to various cities without
telling the governors or Mayors people
that is stunning I mean think about that
the accusation of facilitation is one
thing which means come through any way
you want check in for a fake court date
never go home if those reports are true
that in in actuality we're just flying
them straight from those countries that
is straight up facilitation which is why
there are members of the House of
Representatives who want to bring an
impeachment vote on Joe Biden for
abdication of responsibility of our
Sovereign borders we'll see where that
goes as it moves to committees but a lot
of people recognize uh this has nothing
to do with border security and
everything to do with flooding our
country I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis